Hey folks, making something interesting
today. Uh,
one of my favorite uh, dipping sauces
now is from Wendy's and it's their uh,
their ghost pepper ranch dipping sauce.
It tastes great, but it has no heat.
If you've ever had Wendy's ghost pepper
ranch dipping sauce, you you know the
same thing. You know, it tastes really
good. It's a really good ranch. It's got
just a little bit of heat in the back
end, but not not what you would consider
ghost pepper. So, I've been
experimenting and I think I've come up
with a really good um
probably better copycat than uh than
Wendy's. It's very similar, but uh it's
got a little bit more kick, but not too
much. It's got just enough to like Oh,
yeah. I I I can taste that ghost pepper
now, but it won't blow you away. So,
here's how I'm going to make it. And
then come back and I'm going to give it
a try.
Here I have a cup of mayonnaise and I'm
going to add a uh 1/4 teaspoon of garlic
powder, 1/4 teaspoon of onion powder,
and a half a teaspoon of salt. a
tablespoon of dried parsley.
A half a teaspoon of paprika.
And then the star of the show, the uh
the ghost pepper powder. This is a/4 of
a teaspoon. This should be plenty, but
if you want to really kick it up, you
could add a half a teaspoon.
And then I got a a half a cup of
buttermilk.
And I just want to whisk this all
together. Get it incorporated.
Okay, that looks good. Let's give it a
taste. See if we need to make any
adjustments.
Uh, yep. It needs It needs more salt.
Yeah.
Yeah, definitely needs more salt.
Okay, let me add some salt. I'm going to
add another half a teaspoon or another
1/4 teaspoon actually. So,
that's about, you know, almost a
teaspoon of salt. So, let's see what
that tastes like.
Okay.
Okay. Salt is perfect. There we go.
Okay. Let's let it refrigerate and give
it a taste.
Okay, here's how it turned out.
I portioned it out into a little
container for dipping.
This is what my
ghost pepper ranch looks like.
Here it is. Wendy's.
They look
looks very similar. I think Wendy's is
just a tad bit orer, maybe a little bit
more paprika.
But, uh, that's the two side by side.
Okay. Let's
let me taste mine first.
Give a good dunk.
Got to go in again. Another dip.
Definitely has a really good ranch
flavor and so much more heat. It's it's
not overwhelming like I I was
mentioning. It's really it's it's right
on you. You know that that ghost pepper
is there. You can taste it. You can
taste the ranch. You can taste the ghost
pepper. And uh Wendy's nuggets are
pretty darn good. Let me taste uh one of
the nuggets here with the uh the Wendy's
ghost pepper
just for a comparison.
Very very similar.
Yeah, it's good. It just doesn't doesn't
have the heat level. I have to say one
thing about the Wendy's has a little bit
more of a a vinegar flavor. So, I think
the mayonnaise they use might have like
vinegar in it. So, that being said,
make this recipe with Duk's mayonnaise
and you'll get a lot closer to that that
vinegary flavor.
Dukes. I should have thought of that in
the first place. Well, there you have
it, folks. Want to really kick up
Wendy's uh ghost pepper ranch dipping
sauce?
Or you could cut it in half. Add a
eighth of a teaspoon.
And uh you could actually add a half a
teasp. You could really kick it up is
what I'm saying. That that ghost pepper
um that ghost pepper powder was
fantastic. And it's just pure ghost
pepper. I'll put a link in the
description box below where you can
order that on Amazon because I couldn't
find it anywhere. Well, there you have
it, folks. Thanks for watching.
[Music]